good evening members and officers of the
council and
no members of the public unless you're
watching online
um welcome to this meeting of governance
and audit committee firstly the
housekeeping
if the fire alarm is activated vacate
the offices by the stairs please do not
use the lifts assembly assemble in holy
square on the green officers will assist
you and advise you when it is deemed
safe to return to the chamber
filming does anyone intend to film the
meeting
great um
restrictions on useful mobile phones
would everyone present please ensure
their mobile phones are turned silent
and that they are not used to make or
receive phone calls in the chamber while
the meeting is in progress
please note this meeting is being live
streamed for members of the public the
meeting will be also be recorded and
will subsequently broadcast on the
council's youtube channel
we've received apologies from grant
thornton
um
which is the approach has been received
from nick halliwell who is unable to
travel due to railway strikes taking
place today however nick has drafted
some briefing notes for agenda item 10
the 20 20 21 statement of accounts
and these should have been shared with
members just before the start of the
meeting
under rule 20.1 are there any members
who wish to speak under council
procedure rule 20.1
great
a gender item oh hello hello hi hi uh
yes sorry do you just want me to list
what i want to speak
sorry
uh so
items four five six and seven thank you
thank you councillor
whitehead and
agenda item one apologies for absence
apologies have been received from
councillor braidwood are there any other
apologies for absence
i apologize from
thank you apologies for councillor
hopkinson just to add uh i'll be subbing
for him today thanks
perfect thank you councillor yates
um agenda item two declarations of
interest are there any declarations of
interest
great
agenda item 3 to approve the minutes of
the meeting held on 9th of march 2022
please can have a proposer and a
seconder
i propose chair thank you councillor cup
thank you councillor hounding unless i
hear any objection i will take these as
approved
thank you
moving on to a gender item for the risk
management strategy
um
so
using rule 20.1 would cancel the
whitehead right to speak on the sub and
gender item
thank you very much chair
looking at 3.4
and quoting verbatim
the council has for years identified
limited resources as one of its top
risks this continues to be the case
there have been a number of high profile
mistakes and liabilities some ongoing
and then it remains a local authority
with very low reserves and very little
scope to do anything year on year other
than reduce running costs and to fund
investment in assets from selling other
assets
some other authorities have been able to
create some headroom and risk appetite
to invest in new or expanded services
and or buy assets
both of which can earn a long-term
return
this can support the revenue budget and
so help to mitigate the losses in
external government funding
planet has lived a hand-to-mouth
existence for many years trapped in a
cycle of cost-cutting and a dependency
on ever depleting government funding
without the wherewithal to take the
radical steps needed to lift the council
out of this cycle
we acknowledge that we
effectively desperately need capital in
order to invest in not only our current
assets but also potentially future
assets in order to be able to create
enough funding to keep our own services
going
so from the risk management aspect how
on earth do we manage the risk
and it's not even a risk it's just a
knowledge that we
are going to get less and less funding
to invest in things i know that
we can only strategize within
the realms that we have
but this is the largest underpinning
issue for all of the issues that we face
so how do we manage that as a risk thank
you
uh chris blundell
thank you for your question council
whitehead um
yeah subs it's been right up there on
the top of our corporate risk register
for a number of years now
um
in terms there's two aspects to it one
in terms of the capital um resources
that are available to us and then
secondly
the revenue
budgets there are there is some
interdependencies between the two
obviously the
more assets you've got the more revenue
budgets you need to maintain those
assets in terms of day-to-day
maintenance
and we have um mr porter or acting
corporate director place may wish to
speak to this as well because his um
property comes underneath his
responsibilities
we have a relatively large
asset base within our general fund for
the size of our uh for the size of the
authority that we have
i think it's
my observations of this are that um
asset basis is is too large for the size
of our revenue budget to maintain them
adequately and what we need to do is
rationalize that asset base and
therefore look to
release capital resources through
capital receipts that we can then
select to invest in the appropriate
assets ones that either are of community
value
in terms of providing services to our
residents or alternatively actually ones
that we think are going to generate a
decent yield and a good return
at the moment
our overall investment property provides
a return of about three percent which is
not a great yield
on our asset base so
i think that's
for on the capital side that's the way i
think we've got to go around it is
looking at reducing the size of our
asset base and investing in the right
properties easier said than done because
it's something we've been looking to do
for a number of years but um i'm
confident something we can do going
forwards
in terms of limited resources on the
revenue budget um
i think what we need as much as anything
is certainty of what our revenue budget
is going to look like in the long term
we've got a two-year financial
settlement going into the next year
but that could obviously change with the
you know the change in leadership of the
government
um
what's
what
that makes very difficult for
longer-term planning and we tend to go
through a cycle of broadly knowing we've
got
whether it's one two or three million
pounds worth of funding that we need to
find we don't really know what that
looks like after year one which makes it
harder to make longer term strategic
decisions and we go through this
you know this cyclical process where
every year we're trimming money out of
the budget um no doubt we'll be going
through a similar process this year when
we set the the revenue budget for 20 get
my years right 23 24
where we'll be looking to find compara i
would have thought a comparable savings
to what it was looking like in previous
years unless there's um some additional
funding that that comes forward as part
of the autumn
budget but
um
i think that's unlikely
um
so
yeah it's it's one of those things it's
the top of our wrist register but the
risk is almost
already being crystallized and the fact
that we've been dealing with it for so
long it's almost business as usual we we
know we have to do this um which is
this difficult risk is an uncertainty
and i think this probably is quite
certain that we need to deal with these
things and they're up there to risk
register because they you know limited
resources if it gets worse ultimately
for us it says in the course of the
update it's one of the things that could
take um
control out of our own hands we've seen
that other other authorities whether it
be slow or croydon or northamptonshire
where government intervention is needed
there's something i don't think we're at
that stage um but but it is obviously a
significant risk but in terms of living
with limited resources and going through
an annual budget setting cycle that's
that is something we're used to doing
and i think we will rise to the
challenge and do it again this year um
but it's not an easy task
um and i think again
it's about having open and honest
conversations with our residents about
what we can do in terms of service
provision so
i hope that answers your question i
appreciate it i've rambled on a little
bit there but um
bob i don't know if you wanted to come
in and say anything um in addition to
that
um thank you chris um well not not
massively but i think you are right to
highlight the property portfolio
and i think we all
identify that
matching the size of the portfolio with
the resources available to manage that
is a significant priority um for us and
um
and for the team going forward that's
something we're definitely going to be
looking at uh in the in the near future
and
chris is absolutely right to identify
you know a number of options which might
include
uh reducing the size of that portfolio
but it also
will inevitably include making some of
those assets work work for us more
effectively um and an increasing the
amount of
of income that they generate um
the team have had a look at where they
think
uh we could generate more additional
income and we think there is a
significant amount of uh potential
income
the
one of the main reasons why that's not
been addressed in the past is resourcing
levels
um so it's a kind of circular argument
isn't it really you know we can't
generate more income without resources
we can't fund more resources without the
income and at some point we have to
you know tackle that and say you know we
know that we know the incomes out there
let's invest in the service
and that that through that we can
generate the income so
so it's an investors save strategy
really which um chris and i have
discussed and i think you know we need
to just put the bit more detail to that
to give us confidence that we will
generate the income by investing in um
in in property but uh i think at this
stage we are confident that there are
opportunities there
thank you
thank you
i'd like to invite amy munden jackson to
present the strategy report
thank you very much
so thank you for having me tonight i'd
just like to introduce our new risk
management strategy
and just give you a bit of background
the risk management strategy was
approved in march 19. some of you
probably were here some of you might not
have been and it was up to the period of
next year
the strategy is reviewed annually to
ensure it is fit for purpose however as
the risks the council faces evolve so
does the strategy put in place to
monitor and manage their impact it was
decided due to so many external and
internal factors the full review was
definitely needed to reflect the changes
within our local authority and of course
the wider world so the new strategy
strengthens certain elements
and to ensure that clear corporate
approach to risk management is adopted
so going on to risk context and i think
we've just touched on some of this
actually a moment ago
um so the council has seen many
significant areas of risk emerged since
the last update and the risk management
strategy some remain and some have
evolved and definitely changed in terms
of key risks we've seen the occurrence
of kovid 19 this has had a significant
impact not just on the individual
services but indeed on the council's
operations in general with us having to
adapt the way we work
in order to deliver services around the
government guidelines
brexit continues to play a risk to the
service delivery
they have moved on significantly
and at the last reflex refresh of the
strategy with the overall strategic
vision now clear however new emerging
elephants even linked solely or in part
to brexit such as the recent shortage of
hdv and also fuel remains there
um again the council has for years
identified limited resource um as one of
its top risks i don't need to go into
that
and that continues to be the case and
homelessness sadly still continues to
provide a challenge to us as a local
authority
who has we have a statutory obligation
to provide accommodation but not always
with the additional financial support
that is needed
recently an upward trend in homelessness
um is most likely linked to brexit and
covid and that does remain a significant
risk
and finally governance poses a
significant risk to the council the
progress and conclusion of these matters
both present both the financial and
reputational risks of the authority
but to be fair it's not all bad news
um and so before we start looking at the
changes i just want to touch on some of
the advantages of risk management and
that's why i'm here today
so risk can be a barrier it's definitely
a challenge
and when managed properly this will help
us to achieve our operational and
corporate goals to actually turn it on
its head and it becomes an opportunity
if we have managed similar risks and
have a stirred inconsistent approach to
the way we do treat our risks we can
reduce the chance of failure and help to
engender synergy and also streamline
deficiencies
again using a look across method we can
start to develop coping strategies
through risk management to deal with
developing and uncertain events
and remember the only thing that is
constant is change this is so true we
cannot stop the change but we can change
your attitudes to it
so one of the first big ways that we'd
like to introduce a change to a risk
management is the three types of risk
so at the moment we just look at our
current risk and this really needs to
change as we need to become more
reactive as council and more perhaps
sorry less reactive and more proactive
our current risks at the moment are
probably things that you've seen on our
risk report quarter after quarter
they're very easy to identify they're
tangible we're dealing with them right
now
um but what we start needs to start
looking at is our emerging risk these
are things that are on the horizon it
could be that we've got a thousand new
houses being built and we need to start
planning our service delivery whether
it's waste and recycling etc etc or it
could even be a plan or a big project
coming up we start to need to mismanage
it
um this is stuff in the pipeline any
stuff that we need to plan our risk
management around
probably the trickiest one is our
futurist and this can be hard to predict
but a good example of that would be a
change in legislation if we know it's
coming up we know how to plan for it
again as i said they're very hard to
detect but i'm sure our colleagues have
i have every confidence in our
colleagues
so we're going on something that's
called the pestle approach so we've
looked at three different sorts of risks
and actually we now need to look at the
way that we categorize this as well
so we've identified our risk we know
which type it is we're now going to our
staff start to ask people to drill down
on the types of risk it is and how it
affects their service or delivery
the pest approach isn't my idea sadly
it's a common approach that's been in
risk management for many years and
funnily enough is even on our risk
registers but right now it's not
understood or used it's such an amazing
tool for our guys and it will actually
help them to identify any mitigations
and help to identify where that risk
really does sit
so for each risk we're going to be
asking them to look at political
economic economical social
technological legislative and
environmental it might not sit with all
of them but actually by doing that it
helps them to break down the risk
so we're going to come on now to a bit
more about the rick's risk matrix and
the risk factors
and i'm sure everybody here has probably
seen some sort of version of this in the
past and we've used something very
similar up until now
but we are looking to develop a clearer
scoring matrix for this and as you can
see the way it's worked out is the
likelihood times by the impact so for
example and this is a very far-fetched
example if you wanted to classify a
tsunami which would be very rare your
likelihood is going to be one but if it
was to happen it would be catastrophic
so actually you would find that you
likely hit times by the impact is still
affordable it's acceptable but does that
mean that we shouldn't be planning
absolutely not if we can mitigate the
impact by for instance emergency
planning that's what we would do
but you will get more common risks that
will happen every day will have a high
probability but a low impact so you're
going to look to reduce the probability
because the impact is quite low to us as
a service
and that brings us on to the risk
ratings
previously and you've seen this from
your quarterly reports you see that we
report on everything 12 to 16 and then
it goes down from there what we're
actually looking to do now is to
increase it to five levels and the
reason for that is because we want you
guys to be aware of the amber risks most
of the time these are emerging risks and
this is now going to be highlighted in
an annex on the corporate um gna
document every quarter and i believe
we've got an example of that today for
you attached to the current report
so before we actually go on to
reportings i just wanted to talk about
residual risk and risk appetite
um so we've already we've asked for the
risk to be identified defined classified
scored and mitigated
once they've agreed on their mitigations
they would restore it on the probability
and the likelihood that is then called a
residual risk so that's the risk that
we're happy to take
let me give you an example of this
every day you'll cross the road you know
the dangers of crossing the road and the
challenges around carrying out this
quite simple take daily task
what you'll do is you've got your
mitigations in place place you'll look
both ways you're listening for traffic
you might use a crossing you've done all
of that and you're happy to cross and
that is what's left it's called your
residual risk because you've done
everything you can to stop anything
terrible from happening and this is
where we need to get thanic with this
right of risk attitude
and the right risk appetite
so just going on now to reporting
so again we want you guys to be engaged
we want you to challenge us and by
giving a clear reporting structure and
actually trying to get your engagement
in this this is what we want so
we're going to lay out clear reporting
processes it's going to highlight the
risk that reported the gna by a
quarterly risk report as i said a moment
ago we will now be including amber risks
on the quarterly report these are risks
after mitigations these actually tend to
be a lot future and emerging risks this
is such an important tool for us because
it means that we can start planning for
the risk we can start putting things in
place before it actually becomes a
problem
you know let's be reactive let's let's
be proactive not reactive
it will also stop surprises allow us to
make our mitigations work for us
and of course we're always going to have
meetings this is the council so there's
many many meetings so
um what we will be doing is new annual
meetings with each directorate to ensure
corporate engagement with the process
and to review and refresh our historic
risks
this will be really important to keep
the risk relevant and also to ensure a
top-down approach
this is what we want as the engagement
at every level
i shall also myself be having individual
meetings with risk owners so this could
be service managers on the new strategy
as we've also evolved the risk register
which is i've got an um an example
within your pack as well
there will also be a new section on cmt
cabinet and council reports this is also
to highlight managers who wish to take
full changes or new projects and have
considered their approach to risk
again i will be available to coach and
manage the expectations on this process
so that's really the end of the risk
management strategy i just wanted to
leave you with one closing thought
risk management really is just not a set
of rules policies or processes it is a
culture it's a shared belief and vision
that can only be achieved by a top down
approach
and are there any questions
thank you amy um councillor ghana
yeah thank you for that yeah that was
really enlightening
and i certainly
agree
that um
an organization that
understands and manages their risk
successfully
is more likely to be an organization
that's successful yeah and obviously for
that to happen
um
those members of the organization not
just those responsible for or those met
all members of the organization need to
be responsible for managing this
understanding this so
i'm glad to hear that there will be some
training
uh of people so that especially senior
officers and team leaders are aware
that of what the importance of managing
this absolutely i've certainly
when i i have a project management
background and i soon found that
one of the most important things with
managing this if you're on top of your
risk identifying this yeah and then
managing them you're more likely to have
success absolutely and certainly as i
get older
i've become in my day-to-day life
much more aware of managing risks as i
go about my day-to-day
business like crossing the road as you
say
but um
so it's great to see thank you
um
going back to some of the risks that
were identified in the report
a lot of or nearly all of them were
related to
external factors that planet district
council aren't necessarily responsible
for creating
like brexit
and limited resources
and homelessness there's things we can
do about that but um you know they
weren't out of our creation
the one that
was
possibly of our creation is around
governance yeah i mean obviously that's
something that has happened because of
what's happened to atlantic district
council and and we're more in
enable to be in control of resolving
that risk so have you got or have we got
a clear idea of when we're going to be
in a position to say this risk is now
um able to be
reduced enough
so you know what do we need to do what
needs to happen
for us to be able to close down that
risk i mean obviously there's always a
residual risk right in in terms of the
corporate housing i think i'd have to
refer to chris
i'm afraid i assume that it has
something to do with the recommendations
that came out of the imo's report
yes spot on council ghana i think once
we've implemented
or at least considered and if there
aren't certain aspects of it the
recommendations are not possible to
implement and because things have
changed
so for example one of the
recommendations was
mentoring for the chief executive so i
see the chief executive left so we won't
be implementing that
recommendation directly but once we've
addressed them all
or at least make significant progress
against the majority of them we can look
at reducing the score on the corporate
risk register um
i think without trying to go too i
appreciate this um the following report
covers them in detail but even though
sometimes the scores stay the same
doesn't mean that progress hasn't been
made um so for example on
the corporate governance issues i'm
delighted that we've got um samira here
as our new intern
interim monitoring officer and um samira
khan her
her remit really or the top of her to-do
list will be the implementation of those
imo recommendations
um so we're already starting to make
progress against them even though we've
still got the scores high um but i think
until we've made some significant
headway in them i wouldn't really want
us want us to be
reducing those scores just yet
thanks yeah i agree with you
any other questions or comments
um just to add i wanted to add my thanks
to amy um she's done a lot of work on
this uh
this strategy amy really has become our
corporate lead on uh wrist mansion i'm
probably possibly stealing simon's um
thunder here as well because risk
management was recently reviewed as part
of the quarterly internal audit update
and there were some recommendations that
come out that and obviously we'll be um
looking at implementing everything that
internal would have flagged um we've
been able to um share some best practice
that internal very being kindly pointing
us in direction with some of the other
authorities in east kent i think folks
and hive are my favorites uh to name
drop and we are looking to you know not
look trying to reinvent the wheel but um
uh you know use best practice and make
um you know make the most of those
networks where we can some of it that
you'll see in the this documentation
that comes to you does look very high
level stuff that you're seeing on a
continual basis and council of ghana's
points
are correct that there's a lots of it
and stuff that's outside of our control
and often that's why you're seeing it
because it's the stuff that's really
important and right there smack bang in
our face but actually it's important to
get risk management into everything that
we do and actually when you're looking
at our service registers and our project
risk registers so it will be embedded
throughout the whole organization and
hopefully that means that you don't see
stuff coming to this committee because
what we're doing is managing those risks
correctly throughout our day-to-day
business so
yeah thanks amy for everything we've
done on this thank you
great thanks amy the recommendation is
to approve the new risk management
strategy can i have a proposer and a
seconder
proposed by councillor lees seconded by
councillor ghana unless i hear any
objection i will take these as approved
brilliant thank you
moving on to agenda item 5 corporate
risk management quarterly update
chris plunder will you introduce the
update report
thank you chair lots of this has already
been covered in terms of some of the
discussion we've already had on the
previous item
the as i kind of just alluded to you've
seen most of the scores haven't changed
but it doesn't mean necessarily that
um
things haven't changed because a lot of
them are quite dynamic so if i just go
through them in order um political
stewardship is is where it is um i think
we need to
i can't see us changing that score to
honestly throughout given that we're so
far away from elections unless something
dramatic changes over the next
few months
but i think it's been relatively well
managed i must let's say and i am very
appreciative of the continuation of
cross-party working
cyber attack that is high but we are
actually taking further initiatives
against that
risk
we're looking to
undertake further activities i don't
want to say too much because obviously
that due to the nature of the risk
but we are aware of that particularly
the the risk that presented due to
the conflict in russia and ukraine that
does actually present further cyber
risks to us governance i've spoken we
have made some progress on that but the
score at the moment remains unchanged
birth 45 this is a very dynamic
situation there was a report that came
to kaplan i think last month providing
an update on that
but the risks again remain high
homelessness
mr porter may be better to speak to this
but this is i think one of the biggest
challenges for the organization um we've
seen
increased numbers and that's
again that's largely due to external
factors um to that if there's any
questions they're probably better
directed to mr porter on that but it is
something we're very aware of as a
corporate management team and looking to
address
limited resources i've already covered
thanks to the questions from councillor
whitehead
economic resources um this is a actually
it's a bit of a hangover from the the
risk that was previously titled brexit i
think when what we've seen uh the events
in dover actually over the last couple
of weeks have something we need to be
mindful of and actually that risk may
increase if um the events continue over
the summer but at the moment there's no
change to that environment like that
again this is one of these ones amy's
talked about this is an emerging
risk because we don't actually know in
full what that's going to mean for us
and the new risk on the list is the cost
of living
environment that we're operating and we
need to continue to
uh it affects the council in terms of
the supplies that we
that we purchase obviously with their
subject to higher inflation
we're still in negotiations with the
union around pay offers but also we were
fully aware that the impact it has on
residents outside as well so it's not
just an internal pressure for us in
terms of managing our own budgets but
it's very much a real risk for our
residents across the district
and then amy did refer to an amber risk
on annex one so i must make sure i
picked that up
and so you'll see some of the scores i
think the one that's dropped down
previously score after mitigation
covered 19. so that was on our corporate
risk previously but the other two i
think have been on there uh for some
time amen there are any other new ones
on there as anti-social behavior i think
maybe a new one on there yeah i think
that's off the back of some of the
events we've seen on the uh the beach
fronts
um
over the last month or so
happy to take any questions
councillor duckworth
yeah not a question but um just a point
on the roles and responsibilities
um the portfolio hold of corporate
governance i think i don't think it's
that anymore i think it's the leader
okay
councillor whitehead
thank you chair
both homelessness and cost of living as
pointed out are in our very highest
category of risk classified as extreme
and both of them are unfortunately
intrinsically linked with each other
again although i'm aware that this is an
ongoing theme so much of this is
dependent on central intervention
we have previously taken sensible
measures to protect residents and our
service provision such as beginning an
in-house temporary housing service
but while this service is in its infancy
we have significant numbers of residents
placed out of area and disruption to
families and children as well as direct
costs to us that add to our financial
struggles as a council
and only growth and direct investment
can change this
what can we do directly and financially
to further invest in measures that can
help our residents with our ongoing
crisis in terms of housing
thank you
if uh if he doesn't mind i think given
we've got the expert in the room i'll
defer that one to uh mr porter
thank you that's quite a broad question
isn't it
um you know that there's there's things
that we are doing and can do on a number
of different fronts um
uh to tackle this issue
um
and obviously the the first um
the first key action that we're doing is
in terms of delivering new affordable
housing um and one of the key
things that we
know it sets out within our own housing
strategy um and our own uh
hra capital program is the desperate
need for additional affordable rent um
and
so obviously we are delivering a program
of affordable rent and the council is
committed to
funding into the future to continue that
program
at a level of around about 8 million
pounds a year over the coming 10 year
period
which we think can deliver about 300
homes over that time
it's not enough on its own and we're
also working with housing associations
um
one piece of good news on that front is
actually the housing association supply
is due to increase quite significantly
this year and next year um over the last
few years
they've been delivering
you know 30 40 50 units a year um and
this year and next year we're likely to
see that increase to 180 200 units 180
this year and 200 next year so that's
going to
make a fairly significant impact
um
the the other
part of that is our our response to
people that are facing homelessness and
how we can support them
and we've introduced a range of new
services
to try and help people
stay in their home um or
indeed find another home in the private
sector that's affordable to them
which can include uh intervention in a
dispute between the tenant and the
landlord and we've got officers that do
that
we can provide financial assistance to
people facing homelessness
either with rent deposits or rent in
advance
we can support the reduction of
tenancy related debt such as rent
arrears if it would prevent somebody
being homeless and keep them in their
home
on the basis that it's cheaper for us to
do that and pay for
temporary accommodation um
we we've also
um can signpost people to to benefit
services and citizen advice services to
make sure that they're maximizing their
income um in the accommodation they've
got um
all of that of course
you know is dependent on us being able
to find accommodation that is
fundamentally affordable and
the the private rented sector has seen
significant cost increases in the
district uh to the point that people
that are reliant on
housing benefit or the housing element
of
income support are unable to access that
even with those those support measures
in place
i've just checked the figures
this evening we have 186 households in
temporary accommodation
um at the moment um and and many of
those are outside of the district
the the kent housing group
is a partnership of
all of the local authorities
in kent and housing associations doing a
piece of work to look at the temporary
accommodation position for all local
authorities in kent
and that same pattern is emerging
everywhere
and some of the districts have
significantly higher um
temporary accommodation rates than than
even ours
um of course that means that there's
pressure on the temporary accommodation
supply everywhere
and we've got certainly in the last
couple of months there's been more than
one occasion when the team have said to
me there aren't any temper accommodation
options available anywhere in the county
um so that that is a really challenging
position
and obviously the the officers are
working very hard to
um you know if we need to use for
example hotel accommodation like we did
last weekend when there was a fire
um
working very hard to move people out of
that accommodation into something
self-contained as quickly as they
possibly can
ideally in the district but sadly at the
moment that's not always possible
so
you know there's a whole raft of things
there that we're doing
i'm sure if the cabinet member for
housing was here this evening she would
also say
that she's uh written to
um
government uh
to seek support for additional funding
for affordable housing
and i know council whitehead did the
same thing when she was cabinet member
for housing as well um
we will continue to push that message
because additional funding for for this
you know really important service for
local people is is essential
thank you
thank you um council yates
yep thank you chair i just want to
discuss this new risk of cost of living
as councillor whitehead has
gone on to it as well um
so we we do
seem to
we do do our part when it comes to the
cost of living with the home energy
officer and supporting local food banks
um
some of the
the consequences
mentioned our impact on residents with
low disposable income increase council
costs um
i guess my question is are we
flagging this risk to central government
um or do we think we've got the
appropriate mitigations
such as reserves in place to deal with
these um the high costs that we are
seeing
um
because i think
um if if we don't have the appropriate
mitigations it sounds like cuts will be
coming
in the next budget
so
um how how many how far can we mitigate
this
um
and if if there are no
interventions with uh cpi well i think
it's 9.1 in this report it's gone up
since then
um do we think more cuts will be coming
thanks
i think there's um there's two there's
two aspects to that i think uh mr porter
right said um councillor joel baker's
written in terms of the impact on
communities um and homelessness um and
that obviously is a a real risk for us
and though as you might say this stuff
that we are doing in terms of the home
energy officer to help residents manage
those costs but there's probably only
not to diminish the work that's done
there's only
so much that we can do
given it's a global inflationary issue
that we're dealing with
in terms of our own
budgets
um we always continue to bang the drum
to central government um i take every
opportunity i can
to anyone who listen to me
to make the case for local government to
have more funding
and um but
if you look at the sector actually uh
and speaking candidly the
what it looks like from the authorities
have closed their accounts already the
reserves have actually gone up last year
compared to previous years which is
across the whole sector which is not
uncommon actually in times of crisis
because authorities tend to want to hold
money back and not spend immediately
so given the fact that local authority
reserves have increased
that's a very difficult angle or sales
pitch to make to government who typ who
typically tend to believe that local
authorities have enough in the bank
in terms of reserves
to
mitigate
um
providing you know additional funding
as an alternative
i uh as a kind of i think i come in
which item i said earlier i think it's
highly unlikely that we will get any
additional funding from government as
part of
the budget setting process however i
think i said that around about this time
last year and then we got a load of
additional funding um so
it's very and without you know with the
absence of a crystal ball it's very
difficult to gauge as to what level of
funding would be
forthcoming
um will we need to make further cuts i
think we've had to make reductions in
spending pretty much every year for the
last 10 years
will we need to make some further
savings i think that's likely
but
the
the scale of those i can't comment on at
the moment it's too early for me to say
thank you
council of towning
thank you
do we know how many empty homes we have
in the planet at the moment
and
i understand that there is a possibility
that central government
does uh fund the acquisition of property
to get them out out of being left empty
and vacant for many many years have we
looked at that possibility
um mr porter obviously has uh within his
room it has an empty homes team so we
may be able to talk to that
in more detail so there's work that we
directly undertake as a as a council to
try and um get vacant properties back
into use um that's why bob's probably
looking some of the figures in the
background um
in addition to that i know that we're
we're now able to charge additional
levies in terms of council tax on
properties that have been empty for a
longer period of time and that's um once
it's been vacant for four years i think
there's uh or no sorry ten years there's
a four percent uh or four times not four
percent sorry four times premium so
effectively if the property's been empty
for
uh ten years they're paying five times
the amount of accounts that's they would
do normally and that's scaled i think
after two and three years there's
different um factors that are applied to
that rate which obviously acts as an
incentive there are some loopholes that
people can apply um to be honest
unfortunately it's not straightforward
if the property is deemed to be an
inhabitable which means that they've
ripped out all the plumbing and the
kitchens and the bathrooms then it said
it's not eligible for council types
unfortunately sometimes that's the
situation we get in those properties
that have been empty for a long time
those are the sort of um
approaches or tactics landlords will
take to avoid paying those um uplifts um
but um overall um
well i should probably stop
wrapping on about council tax bob have
you got anything more that you can say
in terms of what we do from a service um
delivery perspective yeah yeah um
absolutely um so i was just um i'm glad
chris spoke for a little while because
it gave me a chance to look it up but
on the um on the council's website we
actually publish
amongst the corporate performance
indicators
both the number of empty homes in the
district
and the number that we've actively
participated in bringing back into use
so that information is
on the council's website on a quarterly
basis the last published figures
1458 empty homes
um so then that that doesn't include
second homes uh that includes any empty
home but it
it doesn't include uh homes that might
have only been empty for a very short
time so you know whenever there's a
change of occupant the property is going
to be empty for a period of time the
ones that we focus on are the ones that
have been empty for more than six months
um and that generally is around the you
know a thousand
eleven hundred kind of mark i don't know
the exact figures to hand at the moment
but um that fourteen hundred and fifty
does include short-term empties as well
as long-term empties
um
the figures for the properties we've
been brought back into use actually have
been steadily increasing uh over the
last 10 year period and actually the
team consistently have been doing more
and more in terms of bringing empty
homes
back into use and we've been pushing
that performance target up
to try and get more from the team
and we use a range of powers to
encourage
uh owners to do that
it isn't actually against the law to own
an empty home
so you know we can't make somebody
occupy or let their home
but we can take action if it's in
disrepair or if it's if it's
causing
damage to a neighbouring property or if
it's affecting um the the neighborhood
there's there are tools that the team
can use uh to take action to encourage
the landlord to bring it back into use
we also
provide quite a lot of advice about you
know options to landlords
and one of the options that um
we can assist with is encouraging
landlords to sell their property to
somebody that is going to bring it back
into use and we can help landlords put
properties into into the auction
particularly if they're in very poor
condition uh we've we cannot um
facilitate an auction for owners
discounted auction fees
um we work with the county uh very
closely on their no use empty program so
uh which offers loans
uh to owners of empty homes to bring
them back into use and let them um and
actually
the county spend more money in thanet
than in any other district in the county
bringing empty homes back into use
the other document i'd point you to
is our empty homes plan which is also
published on the website uh under the
housing
pages and there's quite a lot more
detail in there about about how we
prioritize the team's work uh which
properties we focus on and the tools
that they use to bring homes back into
use
so hopefully that's helpful
counselor tony
thank you
uh one of the major concerns which is
not on your chart and you mentioned it
uh chris was anti-social behavior
constellate and i have experienced
from our local residents constant
what you call emails we've had meetings
with police and so forth
the point is that there isn't enough
protection being offered
to residents not just
local authority residents i'm talking
about homeowners who've had bricks
thrown at their their homes and so forth
i mean what is
the possibility that the council i i
know that the the cabinet for example
are very concerned and they have
actually i have had actually discussions
with
uh councillor ashby about this as well
and she expresses serious concern and
there is not enough resources of in in
the sense of enforcement
is there is that because we are not
sufficiently funding the matter or
or what is the situation and how can we
address it to overcome some of these
problems thank you
um
it's obviously it's a very
complex
issue
in that
some of the things you referred to there
are what i would consider
way well beyond antisocial behavior and
actually just into the realms of pure
criminality
and once you're dealing with um
behavior of that nature it's actually
that's the responsibility for the police
to get involved
rather than our enforcement
officers
unfortunately we've not had as much
money available to us this year the last
two years we had funding from kcc
contain outbreak management fund comp
funding that we're able to use to
deploy for additional
enforcement
activities around the town and on our
beaches and foreshores
we weren't able to secure that money
this year so there is there is less
money available and consequently less
enforcement activity
but we are working closely with the
police our um multi-agency task force
monitors ct cctv footage and liaisons
where the police provides information to
them
a lot of the issues we we know are not
um
instigated by residents of thanat and
we've got issues with um particular
groups coming down on the train at the
weekends and therefore then we're
liaising with british the the transport
police to try and identify
um
early on before they arrive if they're
when they these these groups of
typically but not always
younger
male and
younger males coming on um
to the train further up the line
um so that we're prepared for where
they're coming but
i think for me going back to another bit
a lot of it really is
pure criminal behavior when you're
it's not just noisy teenagers and that's
anti-social behaviors
you're doing as you say people dealing
with you know throwing bricks or or
fights i wouldn't want our enforcement
officers to be getting in the middle
honestly into a middle of a fight
because if you've got one or two
enforcement officers and you're asking
them to get in the middle of a fight of
30 or more individuals on the beach
that's there's there's no way those
enforcement officers are in a position
to stop or de-escalate that fight
effectively um so
really
unfortunate unfortunately or or for what
other reason we're looking at a
situation there where i think
i'm not saying the police are not doing
enough i just want to
make that clear but it is the realms
responsibilities for the police to
enforce those uh activities but
councillor cup i believe this is this
your portfolio i don't know if there's
anything else you wanted to say in terms
of the activities um or initiatives that
we've been undertaking
um so i mean obviously uh penny the
director of safe neighborhoods she's
been uh in constant contact with the the
police because as chris rightly says a
lot of these matters are uh criminal
matters and they're off after the police
to deal with our um enforcement officers
don't have the power the sufficient
power to
uh warrant to go in and deal with some
of the situations that are happening
we
the the biggest issue that we are facing
is people that are coming down here um
as tourists and then uh using our
facilities and taking liberty with them
really um and a big thing that we are
have been looking at is with the british
transport police
over the summer they have been more
visual on our trains to make sure that
they are actually um being been seen on
trains and
southeastern as well have been made sure
with their ticket offices that they are
uh more visual at the station so that
people have actually got tickets coming
into the local area and those that
haven't are being refused to entry as
well
um
a different kind of approach that i have
been talking with penny about is that i
think that it's all very well and good
that uh we can ask the police officers
to go and investigate these and be seen
on the street but i think as a
uh our social media kind of element of
it our engagement with the community
needs to be a little bit better um and i
have suggested
putting my acting hat on and kind of
giving a bit of a briefing about what
you should be doing when you come down
to the beach picking up your litter
actually reporting the behavior when you
see it going on
and i think we need to be a little bit
more proactive
on the social media side of stuff to
show the community that the council is
actually you know we are on their side
and we are here to try and help where we
can
thank you chair
any other questions or comments uh
councillor lees
um yeah just one on uh cyber attack um
please
5.2 paragraph two
at a time when the majority of staff are
working from home due to the pandemic a
much higher reliance on it systems is
needed and therefore the risk of
disruption to the council services as a
result of cyber attack is heightened
have we had a look
um at potentially
um
you know bringing working from home to
an end to try and mitigate this
um
seems like a bit of a no-brainer and an
easy win for me thank you
chair thank you um it's a very good
question i think it's very topical and
current question we've had a flexible
working trial um
in place for
over a year it's just been extended for
us to consider
um flexible working brings issues but
also benefits i think
um
there's there's kind of a
i think a broad
acceptance that we need to have some
form of flexible working still available
um i think if we were to
require
all staff to work in the working home
work in the office five days a week now
we'd have significant recruitment and
retention issues
a lot of staff we're seeing i could say
particularly in the interim market when
we're trying to get people and won't
even come into the office at all one day
a week they just expect to be able to
work remotely
in terms of the risks
of
staff working from home more so
i need i think that it needs to be
balanced off and any risk that you're
looking at you need to look in the
broader terms if you have yes this
clearly is a risk to us
i'm not sure how much particularly the
home working has but i can get some more
detail and and let you know um how much
of an impact that is
um but
for me
i don't think we're in a position where
we'd be able to say all staff back into
the office
but i'll uh value chair refer to
counselor cut um i just want to say on
that point i'd definitely uh
recently in the last month i think um
i'm sure chris will back me up
the office has been a lot busier um and
you there are teams coming back into the
office and it's it's really really nice
to see um when you come into the office
and you're actually seeing teams of
people now
and i think that
more people are wanting to come to the
office again now um now the whole you
know scare of clothing and everything
like that has gone away um and actually
you know i i myself work from home i
hated it you know i i didn't get on well
myself at all um and i needed to see
other people so i think that also
happens here as well but it's really
good to see and i think it's going to
more happen more and more often as well
thank you chair
thank you chair i just could come back
yeah that's that's i think it's an
accurate observation we are saying more
officers come back in um
i i think it would be
uh
bob and i think i'm right on saying on
this that um the flexible working policy
i think we need to rename it carefully
carefully when actually come to an end
because flexible working is a right that
people have that has different aspects
of it
for example if someone goes on maternity
leave forgot the um requirements
or the the right to request flexible
working and obviously we're not
impinging on that
but the remote working aspect and our
policy of how we deal with agile working
i believe that's going to go to
i don't know if it's gpc or if the
employment committee or subcommittee
will be set up but the intention is for
the policy ultimately to go in front of
members so there will be the site and
ability for members to take a view and
ultimately approve that policy
uh one last question then we'll move on
councillor ghana thank you yeah i just
wanted to come back to some of the
conversation about how homelessness um
and mr porter mentioned about there
being
1458
empty homes
which is
in a way is good because it's less than
the
2021 department of leveling up
housing and communities figures so
that's a reduction in those you
mentioned about second homes
and i do the numbers quoted in that
from 2021 was 1733
and
they they also mentioned there's
1531 airbnbs in the district which is up
by 500
over the last three years and while
there's not a great deal
i think that we can do
retrospectively in
i mean bringing some of the empty homes
back into use which is we are doing but
there's not a great deal we can do about
those retrospectively what we should i
think be starting to consider
more
is
what we allow or what we can allow a lot
of the new builds
to be
and what what what action we can take to
stop
um a lot of the new builds that are
coming being turned immediately
into airbnbs or immediately being
brought up
and left
left empty either as second homes or or
just as investments i mean i'm sure
and i do know i mean other areas like we
know the whitby council did something
about it um for a referendum and you
know i've seen how houses built
at the end of roads
five houses three airbnbs straight away
you know and they're not being used by
people locally who need them so i know
it's not necessarily a
something the governance and audit
committee can do about it but something
as a council we we need to be thinking
about
you know taking some sort of action
some policies to stop that sort of thing
happening so as those numbers don't
increase
thank you
thank you councillor ghana was there any
response
um well
it's a very i mean i don't disagree with
you but it's it's a very difficult area
um there isn't really any legislation
that particularly enables us to do that
i i did read about the referendum in
whitby um i don't think it's got any
particular legal status and i don't
think it's that you know it's going to
lead to any firm regulation in in the
area but you know it clearly signaled a
view from the community there that they
wanted something done about it
um
you know
we have looked at it from a planning
enforcement perspective
um
and um
for
for it to be in breach of the planning
concession
condition as a residential dwelling
there has to be a material change in the
use of that dwelling
um
and so an example
that i would say you know a clear
example where a family home
is let
on a holiday basis to a family
um you know it would be really difficult
to argue that was in breach of planning
control
you know if you had a if you had a a
a house that had been subdivided into
rooms and let then clearly that is a
breach of planning control and we would
want to take action about that uh you
know but if it's a single dwelling let
as a single dwelling to somebody who was
on holiday i think that we would be on
really difficult ground trying to
enforce that
the other aspect about planning of
course is that our planning enforcement
service is a complaints-led service so
you know if people make a complaint
about the change of use of a dwelling we
would investigate that but we don't
we're not able to proactively
you know go out and look at every
registered second home and consider
whether we can take enforcement action
against him we just don't have
the resources to do that but if people
make complaints about a specific
dwelling
being changed
having a change of use then we would of
course investigate that
thank you
very quickly so we can move on council
whitehead
yeah sorry it's a very quick comment
just to answer councillor ghana um so
i've spoken to a lot of officers about
this issue
and
to my mind the best way to deal with it
is to
get a new planning use class in place
but that requires central legislation to
do it but we did write to central
government i think about
a year ago to request a new planning
youth class to deal specifically with
short-term rentals
um so
that aspect of it has been done and
requested but there's been no reply
thank you
thank you and the recommendation is to
approve the review of corporate risks
please can have a proposal and a
seconder
proposed by councillor lee's second did
by councillor yates
and at this point
unless i hear any other objection i'll
take this as approved
perfect thank you at this point i'd like
to say thank you to amy please go have a
nice evening who knew risks was
an interesting subject
okay
moving on to agenda item six the
quarterly internal audit update report
uh manages you to simon webb from east
kent audit partnership to introduce the
report
thank you chair good evening members
this is our regular quarterly internal
audit update report which summarizes the
work undertaken by the east kent audit
partnership on your behalf since the
last meeting of this committee together
with performance of the partnership to
the 31st of may
if i could direct your attention to the
table on page 45 of the agenda pack
that summarizes the nine new audit
assignments completed during this period
we were very pleased to
conclude
uh wholly substantial assurance in the
areas of budgetary control and also ict
procurement and disposal
in terms of food safety we concluded
substantial assurance in that area there
was a partially no assurance opinion but
that relates wholly to gdpr issues
surrounding document retention which are
largely outside of the control of the
food safety team as it is a software
issue which is being investigated with
software supplier
there were three areas where we
concluded reasonable assurance they were
the operation of ramsgate marina
electoral registration and election
management and also risk management
which we've
obviously dealt with in some depth this
evening
in terms of tenancy and estate
management we were very pleased to
conclude largely reasonable assurance in
that area the limited assurance aspect
of our opinion relates to grounds
maintenance standards or the lack
thereof as they pertain to
estates within the council's control
housing repairs of maintenance we did
conclude limited assurance but i would
say that the direction of travel here is
very very positive um from the situation
that you inherited from escape housing
um some 12 to 18 months ago
it's not quite um time for us to
conclude reasonable assurance in that
area
there are still areas for improvement
but as i say the direction of travel is
very positive all things considered
uh cctv unfortunately we concluded no
assurance in this area due to lack of
privacy zones on the cameras within the
district inadequate signage
as you enter cctv areas
amongst a number of other issues
there's a lot of easy wins for the
council here to improve
the control in that area and indeed
management have already advised us that
they have implemented a number of the
agreed recommendations um including that
surrounding privacy zones on the cameras
uh we will be undertaking a follow-up in
the coming months to evidence what
management
advices that they have implemented and
we will be bringing the results of that
follow-up back
to if not the september certainly the
december meeting of this committee
follow-up is a very important part of
internal audit work
we don't just take management's word
that they've implemented
the recommendations that we've agreed
with them we go back typically about
three months after the original audit
and
follow up the recommendations that have
been agreed
if i could draw your attention to page
55 of the agenda pack that summarizes
the seven follow-ups undertaken during
this period it shows the original
assurance level and the revised
assurance level after follow-up together
with a number of original
recommendations and those outstanding
after follow-up
there were two areas that were still
limited assurance after follow-up
one was dbs checks now there
that
the reason for that is solely that um
the council had done about 50 of the dbs
checks that it needed to do
but that situation is improving pretty
much on a week by week basis
we do have a review of safeguarding in
the agreed 2223 plan and that is briefed
and agreed
to start
in the late summer early autumn so we
will be further following up the
position with deep with regard to the
completion of dbs checks at that time
and of course the results of that
safeguarding all day will come to this
committee
hopefully um the number of checks
undertaken by that time will be
significantly higher
the other area where we concluded
limited assurance after follow-up was
commercial let properties and
concessions i think we've already
touched earlier in this meeting on the
fact that the council has a very large
property portfolio
but unfortunately limited resources to
maintain that and there were there are
issues surrounding rent reviews falling
behind
which of course result in less income to
the council so there's quite a lot of
recommendations there still to be
implemented
it is an area that has suffered slightly
from the fact that there's been a number
of interim directors in post during the
period under review i think we had a
different director for the original
audit to the follow-up and indeed i
think we now have
a third director
the annexes uh two-hour reports are
those that uh you will be familiar with
from previous meetings of the committee
um annex one shows completion um
against the agreed 22-23 plan
um as that 31st of may we had completed
18.53 of the plan
um i can update you that to the 30th
30th of june i the end of quarter one
we've done 22 against the target of 25
so
we are very close to target um at the
end of quarter one
annex two on um page 62 of the agenda
pack um
includes our definitions of what is
substantial assurance what is limited
assurance
etc
um annex 3 on page 63 shows those um
recommendations that are outstanding
after follow-up they are the ones drawn
from the follow-up table that i
mentioned on page 55
and finally
we have an annex that shows
those areas
that we still need to undertake
follow-up of things like cctv which
they're not yet due follow up but we
will be undertaking that in the coming
months
thank you members um thank you chair
obviously happy to take any questions
that members may have
counsellor
garner
thank you and thank you thank you for
that report
um i have to say i share
i share your
concerns as stated in the report about
the commercial let properties and
concessions um
we as we mentioned earlier you know
that's a high value area you know that
which we could be reaping a lot more
reward from
and to have had
no change whatsoever
um
in the
since the last
audit
is really very disappointing despite the
fact we've got a new we haven't had a
director of properties and i know we
have got somebody in now um so i think
i think it would be worth us considering
asking the
the director to to come to the next
meeting to
to give us
uh well i'm sure by the time he did come
to
the next meeting there would be a lot of
improvement so it would be good
to him to come and for us to be able to
hear
what changes have been made and so to
help us to better understand what some
of the problems were and
what some of the changes are that have
been put in place to improve the
situation
so
that's my proposal anyway
thank you councilman garner um bob would
you like to speak on this one yes please
thank you chair um
i know that we've been through a lot of
changes recently and it's quite easy to
lose track of who's managing what is
there at the moment but um just for the
um
the committee's benefit the the director
of the new interim director of property
actually reports to me in my current
role
um and um
mark peace his name is um he and i um
have discussed this at length and i've
also had conversations
um with mr blundell about it um
and clearly you know it's a it's a top
priority for us to resolve those issues
and get the resourcing in the team right
to be able to deliver some of the
outcomes that we want to see
and that are highlighted in in this this
report
i'm more than happy for
us
mark and myself to bring back
an update for the committee on our
resourcing plans and improvement plan
for the service i think that would be a
really useful piece of work to do
and um you know it will give us
framework to to take it forward
um
you know we've kind of
you know tackled areas where we've had
significant improvements needed before
um you know for example the tenant
leaseholder service where we brought it
back in-house and it had a huge amount
of work to do and i think properties in
a similar sort of condition
um you know my view of this always is
you can't do all of it in one go
and
you know having a an improvement plan
that sets out what we can achieve over a
period of time i think would be really
helpful both for members
and for officers um so that you know we
can measure the improvement and and we
can give the officers something to work
towards so um i i think that would be a
really helpful piece of work and i'm
happy to commit to doing it thank you
councillor yates
uh thank you chair just um i guess i've
got a two-part question
very very similar actually to what
council ghana's saying
i'm on exactly the same point
um and again it's about
uh commercial property and concessions
it's been highlighted as limited
assurance um
so my first question is to simon thanks
for the presentation it's when was this
kind of first brought up as a risk um
and then i think i'll come back with a
second question once again
thank you councillor um in terms of the
follow-up that was done
sorry
uh in april 22 the original audit
um would have been about uh three to
five months prior to that so the latter
part of 2021
uh thank you i'll just ask my second
question um the reason i ask is just
because i've been hammering away on this
issue since 2020 and
had very little joy and there are some
reasons for that um
i think one thing
that just want to highlight here is
during
um
uh
during recent years we took over the
margate harbor arm which was paying a
pound a year to tdc and now tdc is
receiving around 100 000 pounds a year
of income from some of these commercial
properties is it not the case that we
can use some
some of this income
um
on an ongoing basis to have
a larger number of staff in the estates
team because
um
it seems only fair that if you are
managing the property and bringing that
in that income then you should have the
staff um to deal with that
um to deal with especially the rent
reviews and the ensuring that um
the properties are up to scratch and
meeting the requirements thanks
uh i'll pitch that one if that's okay
council yates um
if i recall correctly
um
the income from the mar gate harbor
armour is actually used to
balance the budget within the property
service so as has been reported to
cabinet
within our finance
budget monitoring report there have been
deficits on income within the property
estate they're under um
under budget in terms of the income that
they're receiving what obviously creates
a gap for us and we've used that
additional income largely to try and
reconcile and balance the budget so
unfortunately that's already been
accounted for um but
as mr porter said we are looking you
know we're having conversations and
looking at what we can do because there
are there is additional income that we
can get from our commercial property and
concessions and we need to make sure
that we resource it correctly so that
we're not continuing this chicken and
egg situation where we're not able to
get that income in because we haven't
got the resources
it may be i think that we need to deploy
some additional temporary resources to
do that
i'm not sure how we fund that but we
need to find a way what i'm
what i am
keen to make sure that we don't do is
deploy
a substantial amount of permanent
resources into the service which could
then be at risk if the income
doesn't
come to bear or if there are significant
significant funding reductions you spoke
about earlier so i think unable to keep
us sort of nimble and agile
it would be preferable from a financial
planning perspective if we can look to
do something that's um
a little bit more flexible but all
options are on the table
thank you
councillor towning
thank you it's a
point to bob
um following all from the council
gardens point about the director of
property coming here
i understand that he's looking at the
portfolio of
the tdc's or than its
property portfolio i mean wouldn't it be
beneficial when he does come to talk to
us about the property portfolio that he
gives us a much wider uh spectrum of our
of our of how he views the future of
going forward with the uh with our
property portfolio rather than identify
just limited areas so that we could
understand what the future holds with
regards to either disposal or rentals or
whatever
i if that's what the committee would
like i'm sure that we can do that i
think that would be helpful
great thank you
councillor whitehead
thank you chair um i know that we've had
a lot of movement in relation to
strategy and policy in housing recently
um but in relation to the housing
policies in need of alignment with
national standards where do we now stand
or what do we still need to prepare
thank you
um sorry i'm which national standards
particularly you
referring to
i'm in the wonderful situation of my
laptop having died on me right
[Laughter]
so i think there were three policies
that needed alignment with one of the
four national standards but i can't
remember off the top of my head
um
maybe it guys suggest could we have a
perhaps conversation not um
after the meeting yeah of course and i'm
more than happy to um
answer that but obviously it's quite
difficult to know exactly what standards
we're
about the estate management policy
and we're talking
lining up with the homes
thank you kristen christine's come to
our rescue it's very hard isn't it when
you've got two people without access to
the report um so yeah that the estate
management policy
um so we have
been working hard on the state
management policy uh dealing with the
way we manage communal areas of
buildings and
areas of land around our buildings are
held within the housing revenue account
um and um the the regulations that uh we
want to align to our regulations um from
the regulators for social housing
and
we will be bringing that policy through
the housing
cabinet advisory group
um and um and on to cabinet and actually
with previous ones we've also taken them
to screw the scrutiny committee on the
way
which i think is always helpful
so the next cabinet advisory group i
think is scheduled for september um and
the estate's policy should be on that
agenda
thank you
councillor duckworth
it's probably for chris i think so with
the disposal of ict equipment
are we um
in contact or using organizations which
we use
ict equipment which should feed into our
climate emergency
i'm afraid i'll have to get back to you
on that one i know that we we have
looked in a number of cases and
where possible to sell devices to staff
where there's an interest at a
reasonable price
but obviously as you said it's important
that we're disposing these devices in a
responsible way um obviously the
security of them is important that
they're wiped as well
but i'll get back to the full answer on
that one
councillor lees
thank you um i'm very new to the
committee so forgive me if this is
something you're supposed to know um
under
on the same point on ict
disaster recovery
um on the original number of
recommendations versus the outstanding
number um there are now no outstanding
number of recommendations
but the revised assurance level is still
reasonable how does it how do you go up
the next level if that sort of makes
sense
thank you councillor it's a very good
question um
it really depends upon how embedded we
feel the recommendations are at the time
of follow-up um
if something was reasonable um at the
time of the original audit um it is very
rare for us to put it up to substantial
because the level of testing and work
that we undertake um
as part of a follow-up typically is only
a day's work
that doesn't give us enough confidence
to put things up to substantial um
that timing does depend upon the number
of recommendations if there's a
significant number of recommendations
then the length of the follow-up will be
um higher but
it really does depend
upon how embedded those recommendations
are
and often if it's only three months
after the original audit
they've only just been implemented
so we haven't got a body of evidence
to base an opinion on
any more questions or comments
nope great i shall move on to the
recommendations um that one the report
be received by members two that any
changes to the agreed 20 22 to 23
internal audit plan resulting from
changes in perceived risk detailed at
0.5.5.0 of annex one of the attached
report be approved
three that members consider where
appropriate requested an update from the
relevant directors to the next meeting
of the committee in respect
of the areas identified as still having
either limited or no assurance after
follow-up and four that members consider
registering their concerns with cabinets
in respect of any areas of council's
corporate governance control framework
or risk management arrangements in
respect of where they have ongoing
concerns after the completion of
internal audit follow-up reviews and
update presentations from the relevant
director please can i have a proposer
and a seconder
proposed by councillor duckworth and
seconded by councillor shrub unless i
hear any objections i will take this as
approved
so so the
the second part of that was
about agreeing to in
invite um
the director of
state this wasn't
yes okay thanks
moving on to agenda item seven internal
audit annual report please can introduce
christine parker from east kent audit
partnership to introduce this report
thank you chair if i may members direct
you to page 78 of the report just spend
a
short while uh talking about the the
sort of the purpose of the report and
why it's here
um the bullets act 1.1 a list for us
that we are required um to provide an
opinion on the overall adequacy and
effectiveness of the council's internal
control
environment and then present that
summary of the work
undertaken to formulate the opinion
we are required to draw any attention to
issues that we judge particularly
relevant to the preparation of the
annual governance statement
and it would
in a normal
sort of cycle
this report would come together with
your annual government statement and
your financial statements and there are
reasons um outside of the of the
council's control really with the um
external audit and all of the other
delays as to why they're not all
together at this committee but
ordinarily with this report feeds into
the annual government statement which
you would be required to sign this
evening but that will come at a future
meeting
we also also required to compare our
actual audit activity against what we
planned
and summarize the performance of the
team against that
and comment on our compliance with our
professional standards
and also we are now required to confirm
that we have been able to act
independently impartially without
interference from management
so having set out why we're doing this
report i just take you then to page 81
where we talk about the uh definition of
internal audit and i think the the
impartiality and the independence of
particular words that we draw attention
to
and then to say that the report is
really in two parts it talks about um
our compliance with standards and how
we've performed as a team um in
functioning and delivering the audit to
you in that year and and that's
important
as we've just seen as a set out and the
purpose of the report but i believe
um
the the the crux of the matter for this
report is to talk about the so what in
terms of what what is it that you've
looked at and what are the themes and
emerging comments
so just quickly to touch on the first
part of that in terms of our performance
on page 82 we talk about the compliance
with standards and i do have to draw
members attention to our one area of
non-compliance
and this does also need to feature in
the annual governance statement which is
the requirement to have an external
quality assurance assessment of the
internal audit service i know we talked
about this at previous meetings the
current status is we are relying on our
self-assessment and the four section 151
officers from the four councils that we
work with review that and uh actively
consider whether we want to spend the
money and have an external quality
assurance assessment or rely on our own
internal
assessment and that is the case at this
time so it's the only areas
non-compliance and it is something that
we put on our balance scorecard that we
are partially compliant for that reason
so just to give you assurance around
that
um so moving through the so what in
terms of the overview of the work that
we have done for the year there were 24
projects in the plan that we set out in
march last year and during the year we
have completed 21 there were five work
in progress at the year end at 31st
march to be finalized in april
um and while some
projects were pushed back into the
overall strategic plans some also came
forward which was six pushback and seven
brought forward so moving through what
the results of those work i should also
say members you have seen all of these
individual reports in the four last
meetings of this committee this is the
sort of summary the higher level view of
what what those findings have led to our
conclusions
so in 4.1 we've raised 102
recommendations throughout the year in
our work
and those are split into the percentages
of critical high medium and low risk or
low priority
um so
55
of our recommendations were in the
critical or high risk categories in the
year
and at 4.2 the number of assurances that
we've given throughout the year
with four substantial six reasonable six
limited one no assurance and four
consultancy pieces of work or not
applicable and as i mentioned there were
five work in progress at the year end so
taken together 58 of the reviews were
reasonable or substantial and i think
we're seeing a trend over the years
of that number coming down
in terms of our progress report simon's
quite um
correctly identified this is a very
important part of the work that we
undertake in going back and looking at
those action plans and confirming
independently to members that those
recommendations are indeed implemented
and embedded and the results of our
follow-up there was 15 follow-ups
undertaken during the year and you can
see
the ones that were classed as still
limited or partially limited at the end
of follow-up and what we're trying to
remind members is those were escalated
to the committee at the time
during the year and indeed there were 18
recommendations that were critical or
high-risk outstanding at the time of
follow-up escalated to the committee
during the year and then the number of
reports that were yet to be followed up
at the time uh are in the the table
there as well
so i think all of this what does it lead
us to it leads us to forming an opinion
but just before i
come to the opinion i just wanted to
mention of course the annex um one which
is the east kent services annual report
as well because then of the host for
east kent services and the full annual
report
is shown at page 95 and in summary there
were no outstanding areas of concern for
east camp services
and the number of reviews that we can
completed are shown in the annexes there
as we introduced last year this uh we
have continued to follow a three-way
opinion which is to um
mirror the opinion now that grant
thornton our external auditors will also
give
we are in paragraphs five point one two
and three uh splitting our opinion
across corporate governance internal
controls and risk management
i'd like to stress at this point members
this is a backwards look it's the the
21-22 year that's closed and it goes
only to the 31st of march
um our year
presses reset from the first of april
um
it's a never moving target then if you
delay this report it becomes out of date
very very quickly as as you will know um
in the period april to june 22 the
significant changes have already
impacted the council
um and there have been changes um in
offices at the senior management team
level
that said i'm still required to give the
opinion up to the 31st of march which
explains the wording here before you
and up as as said in paragraph 5.1 there
were at that time significant unresolved
matters affecting governance
arrangements or confidence in the
governance arrangements for the council
and therefore i'm i'm left to conclude
that uh anything other than confidence
remains low in this area
but i will stress that that is up to the
31st of march
for internal control
again what we've tried to do here is
identify some themes
coming out of our work
and the paragraph talking about um
cycles of audits
repeatedly coming back to the committee
with low levels of assurance with
you know each having a completed action
plan agreed with management but at the
time of follow-up we're seeing little
progress at the time of the annual
report we're looking back and saying we
haven't seen this move on and then by
the time it comes back into the next
audit plan we're saying this is the case
and that has been a theme that we have
seen declining and some of those areas
are key corporate objectives for the
council so it is incumbent upon me to
make sure that i'm making this
drawing this to your attention
at this time
so in accordance with good governance
it's expected that this opinion from the
internal audit is reflected in your
annual governance statement when you see
it
of course that should also be an annual
statement to the end of 31st of march
you probably won't see that um until the
september committee at the earliest um
and the committee should feel confident
um to escalate any matters that it still
has concerns out over um and you know be
happy to ask for as you have this
evening a future update reporting and to
come back to the committee
and the challenge i think that we're
setting here is that that process of of
escalating any concerns become needs to
become more robust so that we see those
improvements delivered and become
embedded
a paragraph 5.3 members will be very um
pleased to know that we have reviewed
the risk management arrangements we've
talked about them this evening and that
we are satisfied of that those
arrangements are effective
the report is for noting members and i
am happy to take any questions thank you
thank you christine are there any
comments counselor yates
um yeah thank you very much um thank you
christine um
i don't know how cheap i am by asking
this question but you you say the
reports backward looking
are there any internal investigations
which are mentioned in the report which
have come up recently
that um
[Music]
it is worth us knowing
um
just so i'd ask that
i paused and looked at my colleague
because i'm involved in tomatoes at
other councils and i think it's all
routine here isn't it yes so i'm pleased
to say we are we are delivering
currently we are delivering the plan and
the plan only for than it so the um
annex at the uh in the table at the
previous um agenda item is showing the
work that we're currently undertaking
for thanos all planned work
that's what i like to hear thank you
any other questions or comments members
counselor ghana
thank you yeah i'll just say thank you
to both of you for
for the work you've done and on that
because i know it's been
a bit challenging over the last previous
year up to last march and before
um are you you look a lot happier
thank you
great thank you
um
the recommendation is that members note
the opinion of the head of audit
partnership that members received the
annual report detailing the work of the
east kent audit partnership and its
performance to underpin the 2021 to 22
opinion please can a proposer and a
second us who approve the review
proposed by councillor cup seconded by
councillor lees unless i hear any
objections i will take this as approved
brilliant thank you um moving on to
agenda item eights the annual treasury
management review
2021-22 i will now call upon mr blundell
to introduce the review report
thank you chair um i'll try and keep
this as light and as brief as possible
cause appreciate it is a lengthy report
so this is a backwards look at our
treasury management activity for the
to the past year up to 31st march 2022
saturation management is all about how
we manage our cash
uh our investments are borrowing as
opposed to
how um we're managing our our data our
today today revenue budgets or capital
programme spending so it's more about
cash management really
but that said kicking off
section three does
uh look at our capital expenditure what
we've spent um you'll see in that table
particularly the top blind capital
expenditure gf that's for the general
fund
the last column there shows it's about
seven half million versus a budget of 23
million that's obviously a lot lower
than we would want it to be
i don't have to hand the reasons for all
the variances some of it will be because
of schemes that went into the budget
quite late i expect around some of the
leveling up um and margate town deal
works but the full details of that will
come to cabinet in september
other items there the hra that's not a
bad position i know it's it's 5.3 versus
7.8 but i must say that's much improved
to where we were a few years ago
under east kent housing i'm not just
saying like mr porter's in the room um
but typically we were we were usually
about 50 percent underspent or or more
um under eastern housing so it is that's
a pleasing improvement
um moving further down
i'm not going to spend too much time on
tables 4 in section 4 because they are
pretty technical and they are
um
tables that we need to include for
statutory reporting purposes but if
you'll see the um top of i've got
different page numbers so i won't i
won't refer to my payment page numbers
point 4.9 talks about the debt that we
were holding so
we held 20 million pounds worth of debt
and that's less than we thought we
needed to hold to finance our borrowing
and that's a good thing
so probably the best thing to say is we
can report that we didn't break some
rules um so i'm happy to report that at
section 4.9
um there's also some other um
things that i can declare at section
4.10 and 4.11 saying that we didn't
spend more than our limits so that's a
another positive
um the most that we held in terms of
borrowing during the year was 24.4
million that's at section 4.13
again well within our limits
uh some pretty heavy tables at section
5.1 um i'm going to scoot through these
but people want to ask questions at the
end please feel free to do so or
alternatively i'm happy to spend time
with councillors in a separate session
those of you that
are on our final account working group
who i'm hoping will volunteer again
looking at you council ghana will be
police we'll spend hours pouring over
this when we look at our final accounts
um
5.5
uh you can see here that's the breakdown
of our debt portfolio that 20 odd
million pounds how it's spread so you
can see actually there's a fair chunk
that's going to be coming up to
refinance in this current financial year
about five million pound about a quarter
of that to be refinanced this year
let's uh skip on section six that gives
you a bit of an idea of what's happened
to
uh
uh interest rates base rates
and overnight rates such they've
increased further since this so that's
obviously ends at the end of april but
that's what's that showing uh 0.75 it's
at 1.25 since then so we've had two
further
rate rises since then in the base rate
and then if we go on to section
6.2.5 there's a nice forecast there
that's provided by link who are our
treasury management advisors uh we pay
this
uh this firm to advise us on our
treasury management activities and
they're forecasting so you can see the
rate rises that have been programmed in
we've already had so this was it's
um
when will they provide this looks like
they gave us this forecast in february
so it's a little out of date because
we're already at 1.25 and they didn't
think we were going to get that until
december and that would stay there my
money now would be on we're probably
looking at more interest rate rises from
honest with e and given where we are
with inflation
uh if i scoot further on let's go to
section 7 now
that table and there shows you so we
refinanced four million pounds worth of
debt
in the last year and the dates that we
repaid the vote those money's off the
big one there plumb in the middle 3.8
million pounds it was a quite high
interest rate as well probably because
it was an older debt um three point
three percent um just for uh reference
you'll see there's a couple in there
from salex or salix i'm not sure the
prep
pronunciation is they're not percent
interest rates because they were linked
to
energy efficiency schemes they were from
a government department that gave us
some money um so not huge amounts of
repay but they were zero rated because
um they were linked to energy efficiency
schemes
moving on to section nine
sorry this is me doing this quickly by
the way
moving on to section nine investment out
turn
that shows you that we had uh 47 million
pounds worth of usable reserves so
that's money that's available for
investment
provisionally at the end of uh march i
must say provisionally because we've not
finished our draft accounts yet
and uh whereas it should be say if i've
skipped through it sorry i've gone too
quickly
should be an average rate of return on
here somewhat yes
so our average rate of return on this
uh is 0.1
um so that's not huge sums but gives you
an idea yeah high rolling uh 0.1
interest rate but that did bring in 55
000 pounds compared to budget
um questions um whether the budget
should be revised for next year again i
was saying earlier um
0.1
uh percent on our returns is not not
great but that's obviously where we are
for
the interest rate environment i think
the eurozone's just moved out of
negative interest rates for the first
time and and sometimes it gives you an
idea of what we didn't quite go negative
but we have been very low
um with base rates
uh moving on then
to
section 11. so this is something the
committee's actually asked to note
if you look at that
colorful graph so this is a new addition
to the main body the report this sets
out our capital receipts so the blue bar
are the general fund capital receipts so
um monies that we get from selling
assets red bar is the hra and the yellow
is a combination of two
worryingly that we've not got a lot of
general fund capital receipts in the
last few years and that that impacts on
our ability to invest in assets so it's
next to
nothing that we've got if anything
provisionally for the general fund for
the last financial year
then moving on to capital finance these
graphs might look a bit opaque but i
really like them and i'm going to try
and explain why in a second
if let me get probably to the clearest
one before we look at the years
if i go to section
three 12.3 you've got the two bar charts
there
i like to compare the this is
effectively the value of our assets of
our of all our our assets are worth
about
just shy of 300 million
so if you think compare this a little
bit if you were owning a house
what you what's your house worth so that
the three chunks put together is the
valuable property
the yellow bits the revaluation reserve
so that's how much your property's gone
up in value
since you sold since you bought your
house that's a bit of equity that you've
got because of increasing house prices
the red bit
is how much debt how much of the
mortgage have you paid off
since since you bought the house and the
blue bit is the debt that you've got
left to pay so it gives you a little bit
of an idea of the gearing that we've got
how much of our loan to value have we
got as a prop um a
um
an authority so our assets in total are
worth almost 300 million but we've got
about 50 000 million
50 000. that's a lot that's big numbers
we've got about 50 million um
uh
debt related to those assets um attached
to the um
the property so just going over it again
not just property assets sorry but back
to my property analogy the yellow bit is
your equity that you've got from
increase in
property prices the red bit is the
equity you've got because you've paid
off some of the that that mortgage and
then the blue bits the mortgage you've
got left to play so it gives you an idea
actually that we're pretty low geared
you see some london bureaus that blue
bit would be really chunky and there
wouldn't be much red or yellow because
of the way they've
geared themselves up they've taken on
lots of debt so actually
there is a bit of room for maneuver we
don't like taking on borrowing mainly
because we haven't got the revenue
budgets to pay off the interest but
actually we're in a decent relatively
decent position if there was a good
investment opportunity for us to to
borrow against the value of our assets
and the rest of those charts are pretty
much a variation on the theme
as to whether it's jennifer nature a or
if they're tracked across the um
five-year backward look
so um what are the recommendations so
you've been asked to note the
uh it says the actual but they're still
provisional because we've not finished
our draft accounts yet the actual
prudential indicators in the report make
comments on the report
and recommend to council
happy to take any questions
counselor yates
um yeah thank you john thanks for
support um
the yeah the key
this internally managed funds um we're
getting returns of 0.1
cpi's
9
based on the previous report
so
if if you put a thousand pounds into the
account and compared
um how inflation would i impact over 10
years
versus that 0.1 you'd actually lose 50
of your
savings over that 50 over those 10 years
from my
compound interest calculation
um
so
are we making the most of that cash and
making sure that instead of borrowing
money we're using it for investments
and
are we going to re-look at that strategy
or is that just the strategy that
other councils will be doing just
because it's just most secure
thanks i think it would be um prudent
actually for us to bring this strategy
back to the this committee so this
strategy was last approved by
um
[Music]
full council in february but since then
we've gone into a high interest rate a
high sorry inflation environment so i'm
happy to bring we typically do a mid
year update anyway and we bring that
in september so i'm happy the september
committee to to answer that in detail
and look at what our strategy is i think
it does need looking at again you're
right
if you're getting those levels of return
and inflation's at that level you are
losing money in real terms there's lots
of um
there's lots of commentary out there
around the risks of chasing
inflation-linked
yields or comparable yields because
typically to get better rates of return
higher yields you need to take more risk
so that's something we need to be
mindful of when we're doing that but i
think there's possibly a sensible
compromise that we can make to use our
um our money a bit smarter and deviate
from our strategy but i'm happy to bring
that back as part of the media review
yeah from my side that would be great
thanks
perfect any other questions or comments
great
the committee has been asked to
for the recommendations note the actual
or provisional it should be note the
provisional 2021 to 22
prudential and treasury indicators in
this report makes comments as
appropriate on this annual treasury
management report for
2021-22 and recommends this report to
council for approval please can have a
proposer and a seconder
don't all fight at once
proposed by a council of towning and
seconded by councillor yates
unless i hear any objections i will take
this as approved
perfect
moving on to agenda item 9
update to ripper policy and annual
report i'd like to introduce our
newcomer samira khan to introduce this
report
thank you chair good evening members
you'll be pleased to know my report is
not as complicated as chris's at all and
i'm not about to go into any figures at
all
let's hope not
basically the report that is before
yourself is to update yourselves
regarding the ripper policy which is a
strategy requirement by all councils um
it will come as no surprise that we are
required by law to have this policy
updated and reviewed every year and the
last time this policy was reviewed was
in 2018.
um can i draw members attention to the
to the letter that was attached to the
report which appears on
i think it's page 129 of the report
which basically
outlines the inspection that was done by
the commissioner in april um the
inspection was done in april but it's
taken us some time to bring this report
back to yourselves because of the change
of management um i'm not proposing to go
to the through the recommendation which
is done on the letter but i'll drill
your attention to one two three and four
and various other recommendations as
well which is
recommended by the commissioner itself
um
the
actual policy is driven from the ripper
2000 2000 legislation is under section
26 2
2 6 of the reaper policy um the act
itself
and the local authorities are required
to update that what um i can i also draw
members attention to
page 131 which starts the policy
and it starts off with the introduction
of what ripper is and what as a local
authority we legally require to do it
gives members definition of what it is
and how we are supposed to use the
covert human intelligence sources which
is known as the chis
the there are also the appendices
attached which
takes through the very standard forms of
surveillance application um monthly
reviews and various flowcharts as
members can appreciate the quite a lot
of the flowcharts are really really
extensive and it needs
a master's degree basically to go
through them
so
the recommendation that i've done in the
actual policy itself is asset out and
which is acknowledged by the
commissioner in terms of what we're
required to do um
the only thing i would need to update
members at this stage is that the some
of the recommendation because i've only
just been appointed as of last week some
of the recommendations i've not really
sort of progressed as such but i'm happy
to bring a report back in september
setting up exactly how i'm going to with
obviously section one fire officer and
the interim chief exactly how we're
going to implement them
because the commissioner is very much
wanted an update already from me um in
terms of how i'm going to implement it
so i'm happy to bring a report back in
september and update memphis example
exactly how i'm intending to do that
happy to take any questions i said my
report wasn't as complex as chris is at
all um but i'm happy to answer any
questions
counselor ghana
thank you thank you for the update
um
one of the
you mentioned price that this is a this
is a report that should be reviewed
every year
and the last time it was reviewed with
2018
18
2018
yeah
so it's obviously
four years ago
so it hasn't been done every year so
we
i guess nothing we can do obviously
nothing we can do about that but we need
i'll are we now we've got going to have
this in place we'll be making making
sure that we schedule in
the annual reviews of the policy i i
assume
um if i may share yes obviously i'm an
interim monitoring officer but as and
when the local authority gets a
permanent monitoring officer there that
would be one of their jobs to make sure
that this is reviewed on an annual basis
but while i'm here i will do this policy
i've done the policy so that will be
updated and going forward
it will be maintained
counselor tony
do we know why
for the last four years
this hasn't been reviewed is there any
particular reason
as to why senior management have not
done
that review
uh chair i think i have to
pass on to chris i don't know
i'm afraid i'm pulling a blank on this
well um counts of turning because it's
something i'd like to be able to um
answer but um i think
ms khan and i can have a look at that
and and get back to you with a a more
false answer but at the moment i don't
have anything to hand to to comment on
that
any other questions or comments from
members
um
great uh members are asked the
recommendation uh for the committee is
to recommend and adopt the amended
policy appendix one note the letter from
the ipco the recommendations and actions
and note the report of activity during
the year can i get
that doesn't even say anything about
proposing so that's fine don't even have
to get anyone um moving on to agenda
item 10 uh 2021 statement of accounts
when i'll call upon mr plundell to
introduce for completeness
can i get a proposal please for the
council leads and a seconder
[Laughter]
councillor yates uh seconded and there's
how many objections i'll take that as
approved
perfect
uh moving back on to agenda item 10 20
21 statement of accounts i'll call upon
mr berndale to introduce the review
report
thank you chad i know you'll all be
fighting over to approve and second this
one um
i i believe uh nick halliwell from grant
thornton has shared a briefing note i
hope you've had a chance to review it
i've had a quick skim through it myself
um
essentially this is a holding report um
because the audit's not been completed
yet um
the the there's a couple of key reasons
for that that he set out uh in his
briefing notes um the two kind of
internal to us are relating to
objections and ongoing um audit work
relating to grievances and the birth
four five projects
um and then secondly there's something
that's more sector-wide in terms of
there's been
someone that ultimate wisdom that's it
for the financial reporting council has
got themselves in a bit of it is about
infrastructure assets um we've got quite
a lot of infrastructure assets mainly
relating to our foreshore so all the sea
wall defenses and the like um and
there's concerns as to whether the value
of those assets are overstated doesn't
mean a huge amount to us because
ultimately we we're never going to sell
those i'm not sure there's a market for
selling infrastructure assets of that
nature
but to comply with accounting
requirements we need to do a bit more
work on them
but even when that's completed i don't
think that tells us anything more about
those assets but that's um the my bug
bear and rant over and done with them
that i think it's worth just um just to
be frank that some of the delay probably
does sit with us not just squarely with
the auditors there has been a bit of a
stretch on
resources in the finance team
myself and matt have had some additional
responsibilities to take on over the
last couple of months which has
put strain on the team
and we kind of take the lead when we get
to the nutty crunchy bit at the end of
the audit as well so um that's part of
the reason for the delay
um
thankfully though the audit work that
they've done so far they've not found
anything that's going to have an impact
on the bottom line there's been one uh
issue with the accounts they found but
it's just um
a couple of issues but they're not
anything that affects the value of our
assets or uh how much we spent um and
then he's made a comment on the briefing
note about investment properties they've
recommend strictly in terms of
accounting requirements we need to value
them every year but we don't because we
don't think it's good value for money
because we'll have to pay valuer to
value with some pretty low value assets
so we just say that they're close enough
and we'll pick them up a five yearly
basis the auditors don't like it but i
think it's a better option for um
taxpayers and uh
and councillors to honestly but um
you'll be welcome to comment on that
when they bring the final report
forward finally then on the valley for
money again there's some objections
kicking around some going all the way
back to 1819 i'm hoping they're going to
be
concluded soon and once we get to our
september committee
we can
get those and the accounts closed off
but that's pretty much all i was going
to say on this item happy to take any
questions
counselor yates gone then um
the
the grand thornton investigations burst
405 do we know when that will be
concluded
so grant thornton have to do work on
birth four and five because local
electors residents have um put
objections in i think there's been a few
objections um that have come in
so they need to look at that as part of
their work and that they do to consider
whether we've got arrangements in place
to deliver value for money
the investigation
um or review or audit however you want
to batch it up
that has come out of quentin baker's
independent monitoring officer report
that's not going to be commissioned by
or that's not going to be undertaken by
grant thought and i did ask them whether
they were
well they wanted to i'm not sure that's
the right word whether they'd be willing
to
do it but they didn't have the capacity
to do it so that's gone out um well it's
in the process of going out i've got a
list of five
um
uh audit firms who'll be able to
undertake that work so it's still in
commissioning stage
thanks
any other comments from members
no great
the recommendation is that the committee
notes the reports with the audit of the
2021 statement of accounts please can
have a proposer and a seconder proposed
by
it's a little race now proposed by
councillor cup executive by councillor
tucker
unless i hear any objections i will take
this as approved
perfect that concludes the business for
tonight's meeting i declare this meeting